okay see if I can do this whole thing
blindfolded you know for a hot second
there I did actually consider it but no
no not gonna do that okay bird box so
yeah this was one I wasn't planning to
cover not that it looked bad it looked
fine it's just that you know horror I'm
really kind of picky about I need to
kind of be in the right mood but a
surprising number of people kept asking
me you're gonna see you're gonna review
you're gonna talk about I'm and I decide
based off that alone to check it out I
actually I mean I know it did well in
terms of like being very heavily viewed
I didn't look into how people actually
felt about it in terms of whether or not
response was generally positive and I
actually want to give props to you guys
for that too because all the people who
asked me like are you gonna review it
none of them really clearly indicated
whether the reason they wanted me to
review it was cuz they thought I would
like it or because they wanted to see me
go off on one over it so good on you
guys for for playing that close to the
best so I have now seen it and it's
quite good I yeah I I I mean I knew a
little bit about the premise but I was
quite surprised how good this was just
the the whole thing the waste presented
the acting the the the concepts the
execution I'm not gonna lie I flat out
choked up at a couple of points I may or
may not mention specifically what those
were towards the back end I'm gonna try
to avoid spoilers for as long as I can I
will have to get into spoilers
eventually because yeah I gotta talk
about some stuff that's a little bit
more spoilery so um I'll actually kind
of be able to get my biggest complaint
about the thing kinda out of the way
which is I'm not sure how much the
structure of it actually helps the
narrative and by that I mean you know
it's it's this whole situation where
something has occurred that is impacting
the populace and you know people are
kind of going nuts and taking their own
lives and the the remaining people are
trying to avoid you know the what of
what it is that it's happened but it
jumps back and forth between when it
sort of first hits and the immediate
sort of days and weeks after that and
then five years later with Sandra
Bullock's character trying along with
two small children trying to reach a
safe area and I it's not a bad structure
I just don't know how much it actually
helped the story to be jumping back and
forth as much as it did and in the way
that it did I might have gone with it
better if we hadn't started on the five
years later thing if that hadn't been
the first thing that I saw which meant
that every time we went back I'm looking
around at all these you know other
survivors in going well I assume you're
all dead and it it's kind of a shame
because I actually think that by and
large that that chronologically the
beginning stuff is I think it's the
strongest material that the film has but
it kind of gets the legs cut out on and
from under it a little bit because you
already know this isn't going to turn
out well now that said it doesn't
completely take the wind out of the
sails because it does have a really good
cast and the interactions are good and
surprisingly well-written and avoid some
pretty serious stumbling blocks that
like were directly in front of it that
it almost seemed like it was gonna hit
too so that was kind of interesting I'll
get into those when I start getting
getting a bit more into spoilers
so yeah I'm not in love with the with
the structure of it again it doesn't
completely derail the thing it doesn't
make it suddenly not work I just I feel
like the specific ways in which the
leaping back and forth happens and the
points at which it happened and you know
which stretches we get for how long
doesn't always flow especially well
there's especially sort of a like a a
weird like kind of middle bridge bit
where we've sort of done the five years
ahead leap but it's also before the part
we actually started the movie at so like
there's a weird middle section that
comes in I don't know maybe a little
more than half maybe about two thirds
into the movie and that that was
probably the one bit where it felt like
a lull it felt like an awkward wait
we're coming were disjointed time
additionally one more when we've already
established like these two for more than
half the runtime of the thing so like
that but that's really the only
complaint I'm gonna register on this is
that I feel like editing structure could
have been tighter and they like I feel
inherently that there had to be a way to
construct this film from the the pieces
that there are that would have it flow a
little bit smoother than it does again
it's not awful it works
it's functional but I feel like at some
points it was jarring and I felt like
some moments lost a little bit of their
impact
so that's but that's really my only
complaint viously Sandra Bullock has the
lead and she does really well and she
has a tough job because the character
she's playing Malory is a kind of an
emotionally detached person and we find
that out actually very early on below
but early on in the timeline of the in
the series of scenes that come up in the
film because she's not she does not go
easy on these kids she is blunt she is
insistent she does not leave room for
misinterpretation she is very clear with
them
about the danger they are gonna face and
she does not mince words with them and
then additionally you know we flash back
to before everything went to hell and we
see you heard with her sister who she
very obviously has a good rapport with
but the things that they talk about in
the way they interact it makes it very
clear that her sisters probably a hug
the only person that she has anything
close to this kind of relationship with
and she just doesn't connect well with
people not that like she comes across as
a misanthrope you know something that I
hate everybody she just doesn't make
those connections and it's tough to take
a character like that and have them not
only have an arc that isn't just
learning to trust people you know or
some trite crap like that but also you
know is able to be relatable and she
does really good work in this the whole
cast is good there are only a few other
people who I actually recognized I
forget thing the guy's name but the guy
was rod in and get out he's in it John
Malkovich of course so it's it is it is
it is quite a good cast and they do a
lot to elevate what could especially I
would say actually Malkovich his
character like toe right up to the line
of like I maybe can't quite stand you
accept that especially with some of the
stuff that happens towards the very end
it the the relevance and why he's there
and why things panned out specifically
in terms of history line actually
contributed to the moments that choked
me up later on I think I'm gonna start
getting into more specifics so yeah oh
oh one other thing before I get into
specifics I know some people who have
like made a comparison between this and
a quiet place and they're really doing
incredibly different things I mean
they're they're slightly similar on a
very bare-bones conceptual level insofar
as they both deal with you know a post
apocalypse horror survival situation
where humans
are deprived of something that they are
used to having that day themselves do in
the case of a quiet place it's speaking
and making any noise and in the case of
bird box its sight is being able to
safely just look around because if you
see whatever it is that's causing this
you will go you will lose your mind and
you will you will kill yourself so
there's like at its core there's a
slightly similar conceit but the film's
are doing very different things
structurally and the and the art for
Mallory is very different for what's
going on and they put the characters
they in a quiet place so I actually
wouldn't really ever think to compare
the two under normal circumstances so
that being said now I'm gonna start to
get into spoilers a little bit first
thing I really love that we never see
whatever these things were um because of
some of the the drawings that that we
see we do get hints at sort of the
general nature of it but first of all I
like that none of the pictures look like
they're of the same thing or like in a
similar vein but like well that is
something different from that so and
there's a very Lovecraftian vibe to
those drawings I like that that's all we
get though because I think trying to
trying to show well trying to show us
honestly I think would have just
flat-out killed the movie and even
trying to give an explanation also would
have undermined it because in a way
again core concept it's not dissimilar
from the happening you know the the M
night Shyamalan movie that was not very
good at all and there were a lot of
things wrong with the happening and a
lot of reasons why that movie didn't
work but one of the things that didn't
help was that the eventual reveal of
what it was that was causing people to
go crazy and kill themselves which was
treated like a big revelation and a
twist like and here's the reason why was
really dumb and really laughable so I
think and since this isn't telling a
story really about
the phenomena is telling story about the
people it doesn't matter where these
things came from or what they are or
what their deal is
it honestly does not matter so they
don't even do well on it good call there
were I think there were a lot of just
good choices being made and I don't know
how much of that to credit to the movie
because I haven't read the novel that
this is based off of so most of these
good decisions I'm talking about might
just be reflective of a really good book
I don't know um but as I said in terms
of the acting I okay so I want to touch
back on John Malkovich's character so I
initially I'm like huh okay well John
Malkovich cool I mean I like him usually
and he's his character was the
self-serving jerk there's one of these
like in in almost every you know there's
a group trying to survive story there's
one guy who like wants to not help
anybody else and you know cut his losses
and doesn't give a crap and he's a jerk
I mean that that's that's the long short
of it he's a jerk and normally those
characters really tend to bug me and he
he came very close but I think in a lot
of ways it was saved by the scene that
he has with Mallory after they've
they've gone to the to the grocery store
and and stocked up and you know she
tells him about her father and how he
reminds her of him which is not a
compliment
coming from her and I also like you know
before they they let someone in who was
outside and needed help and you know
what she objected to and when they got
to the supermarket you know they've got
all this stuff and he and his answer was
like let's just barricade and stick it
stick it out here of course there were
still like three or four people back at
his house who were waiting for them to
come back with supplies and he you know
he's sitting there going you can't give
me a logical orally
goal or rational argument as to why we
shouldn't just stay here and Mallory
Ocean goes what we I'm gonna change the
word she is but it's like but we're not
jerks that's why we're not gonna do that
and not only Malkovich is performance
help save it from being too bad in a
little bit a little bit but the other
thing is is that the the first moment
that choked me up and it caught me off
guard it's it's towards the tail end and
they had set this up and that this is
one of the points where the structure
actually worked well and worked in the
things favor because they set this up
then they broke from it by flashing bag
and then they came back to it which is
that they're there in the boat and
they're headed for the rapids and
Mallory knows that the rapids are
dangerous and really somebody should be
looking and that means that somebody is
going to be at risk and if she can't she
can't be the one to look because if she
is if she's affected and she dies these
kids are toast
like no way they're gonna survive on
their own and she says one of you is
gonna have to look and the boy you know
tries to say I'll do it and she goes no
no I'll decide who's gonna do it and by
this point we had learned that the boy
is actually her child her biological
child and the girl is not and knowing
everything that had been set up about
her before like seeing her argue with I
guess was Tom the other guy about how to
treat these kids and how she
rationalizes being as cold with them as
she is in the fact that she hadn't even
given them names as all being for their
benefit
then coming down to this moment
basically a Sophie's Choice moment and
it cuts away from that it goes into a
flashback I don't remember what it was
but it leaves you hanging on that the
wood this idea that she is going to put
one of these children's lives at
absolute risk for the sake of saving the
other one now it's not a guarantee that
whatever child looks is going to die but
it is a very strong possibility and from
a rational how many people can survive
argument that would be the smart thing
to do but when we come back to the
continuation of this scene she kind of
takes a moment she goes no nobody's
gonna look because she made the decision
thinking back on John Malkovich's
character of Douglas thinking back on
Tom piggy back on the people that she
lost over the course of this and I would
imagine probably thinking back on her
own father and her family she makes the
decision that she doesn't want to be
that jerk that maybe it would improve
her odds of living but she wouldn't be
able to live with herself and she's not
going to do that they either all make it
or they all don't and I'm sure some
people could argue that that was a
selfish decision you know sparing
herself the pain of making that choice
but it it is her character arc so
whether you feel that that was
ultimately a smart or a dumb thing that
she decided to do it is the arc of her
character of of recognizing that she is
that she has been and is very much in
danger of becoming permanently John
Malkovich's character of Douglas or her
father or these people who she can't
stand she has become and she
in the pinch moment she has to make the
decision to not be that which is a
decision that on paper may be a stupider
decision but that's the journey that she
as a character is going through and it
was I was surprised how powerful that
moment was boosted by her performance
obviously for the record the other
moment that choked me up was when she
did when we get to the very end it's the
cheesier moment which is what she
actually does yeah finally give these
kids names I was I was pretty impressed
with this by considering I knew nothing
about the source material considering
I'm super picky with horror as a genre
Sandra Bullock can go either way for me
as an actress I think she's a very
talented but she doesn't always work for
me I'd never heard of this director or
seen or even or anything she's done I
was I was impressed and touched which I
wasn't expecting to be none now based
off this premise I was expecting to
maybe be bummed out but I wasn't
expecting to be touched by a moment of a
character who was willfully hard and
cold finally making the choice to soften
that was a that was unexpected and that
was nice
I think I'll wrap it up there Byrd box
have you seen it well goodness was it
hey for you to see it
you shouldn't have looked look whatever
your thoughts on it drops let me down in
the comments let's talk about a whole
bunch of stuff you can do because
there's buttons and links including
what's the patreon any support you're
willing to give is helpful there's also
the address from
p.o box bunch of other links besides
check them out if you want if you don't
that is okay because at the end of the
day you are the council I just run the
meetings and until next time this
council is adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]